Yeah. Yeah. Well, I don't
know. I mean, look funny.
Then when you see pictures of Trump,
he's eating Kentucky Fried Chicken.
When you see pictures of
this dude, he's, he loves her
Trump phrase, Kentucky fried chicken
was fucking private jet hilarious.
He really loves that stuff. He loves
it. He really fucking loves fast food.
Like when he got all those athletes,
when they came to visit them and the
government was shut down and brought them
off fast food, he didn't understand
that. Like what the fuck this shit.
And then he had another team showed up
months later and he broke out the fast
food again. The government was
hope. Just imagine the fucking,
you're going to see the president of the
United States and you're a professional
athlete. Yeah. Right.
Your body literally is a temple and
they were college athletes, but oh,
they're college. I would still
listen. Let's be real about that. Huh?
Carriage athletes should
get fucking paid crazy.
That's the biggest robbery
and all them politic's. Yeah.
College sports cans to get
into the NBA and the NFL. Yeah.
You had a chance if they do,
but you're making billions off these kids.
Fucking billions. Don't give him a
sweatshirt. Money, $20 fucking fast food.
I'm telling you man, this guy,
in terms of like material,
current and future,
it's almost like we glutton down.
It's almost like Trump was ice
cream when he was in office.
He was so good for
comedy that it was like,
there are so many Trump jokes
every now everyone's like, no mo
anymore. Can you take another
bite cause I need something else.
I can't have ice cream.
These like one more bite ice cream is
going to come chucking out of your throat.
It's really true. It's so,
he's so fucking eccentric.
Like good or bad.
Just look at him as a human.
It's such a rare human being. Yeah. You
know? I mean you've seen it with the,
with the hair and the fucking
constant golfing. Even though he shit,
he shit on fucking Obama
Golfing and he's gone away. Him,
he doesn't even try to pretend he's
not a hypocrite. No, not at all.
He's just everything.
He's just the fat American on a jet Ski.
Just letting it rip.
If you know what's also hilarious,
I think this is a real thing.
Trump derangement syndrome.
I think it's real.
You mean people that are obsessed with
him, they're obsessed with, you know,
this is the thing that's going to get him.
He'll be out of office in three weeks
instead of like looking at it like this is
the argument for garlic Michael
Mouse that he's an objective analyst.
Stepping back, looking
at this, he's doesn't,
he doesn't have a vested interest
in this guy winning here,
that guy and when he's just going, hmm,
what is this? Sitting back and watching,
this is if I,
if I'm going to take that position,
not emotionally involved because some
people get so emotionally involved they
can't sleep, they start crying, they
think it's the end of the world.
The world is exactly the same.
We just have a different figure head and
I think it will present challenges that
will make us more understanding
of each other. I really do.
That's what I really think.
I think there's,
there's good and bad
about every situation,
but the pro I see is communication.
If we're just honest with
the way we communicate,
I think people on the right and people
on the left, they share a lot in common.
There's a lot, a lot that
they share rather than what
they don't share in common.
Yeah. You know, the only thing they don't
share is what they're watching. Well,
there's that too. Right. And it's also
the vibe you get. Yeah. I like this.
The vibe from these,
whatever, whether it's CNN,
whatever show you're into MSNBC, Fox
News, they all give out a vibe. Yeah.
And that vibe is, you know, we
are right. Here's what's going on.
Here's why that's a problem.
You know,
and everyone has a different problem
and everyone thinks they're right.
And then you have, so you
have different things. You,
some of them are have like eagles
and flags and Tom, that's Fox News.
Like that's my style. I'm into that kind
of truth. Gimme gimme that shit. Yeah.
Fucking yeah. Yeah. Come on over
here though, right way. Yeah.
All right guys. Yeah, yeah. Oh
yeah. Y'All fucking neighbor.
Let him move in to your fucking
neighborhood. Great job,
Matt. Out trucks and hats.
And guns that could comes your team. That
becomes your claim. That's what it is.
It's the team thing.
Most of it, and, and the,
the unfortunate part is both are saying,
are spending so much time rather than
thinking about this is the problem that we
have to deal with.
They're spending all their time thinking
those other people are assholes. Right,
exactly.
It's being,
it's the venomous attacks against fellow
Americans because they have a slightly
different view about healthcare.
That part is the,
the derangement of the culture right now.